Hey, Prince, how are you?
I'm good, how are you?
I'm good too. How's everything going on your end?
One project, one ticket at a time.
Yeah, OK.
All about progress, what progress you can make in a day, right?
So.
Yep, we cannot take on multiple tasks and then let everyone suffer. Only one thing at a time. Yeah. And it might have been a slow because it's summer. I was speaking to other ISCs and they were saying like, it's good that it's gone a bit slow.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
Yeah, certainly.
Natalie.
Yeah, it's how's your week over there going?
Great, everything is going good. Pretty hot here. So that's one thing on the weather side.
What's the hardest it gets?
It gets around 50 degrees centigrade.
Oh wow, that is hot. How do you manage? I mean, you must live in air conditioning.
Yeah.
So if I would, yeah, it happens most of the times, but yes, when we move out from home, definitely there is no air conditioning. And it's more of like you are in Canada, so you have been accustomed to that temperature. We have been in India accustomed to that temperature. So
Buildings all the time.
That's where the difference lies.
Right.
Right, right, that makes sense.
Just similarly in mentors it gets freezing.
Is it humid though?
Not now, but I can say in July and August it would be very humid because that's when the monsoon arrives and the temperature does not go down. So it becomes very humid. 50 degrees is still manageable, but that time even 40 degrees is not manageable.
Right.
Yes, I worked and lived in the States for a bit in upstate New York.
But.
They do have a lot of, it gets hot, but the humidity there is what gets you.
Okay.
Ohh.
It's that's what gets you. It's always like I can deal with dry heat.
Yeah, that's manageable.
Here in Canada, especially here in...
In Edmonton here, we get dry heat. Just dry, there is no humidity or anything like that. So we manage based on that. But if you go to other places where it's hot and humid, then you're like, you're breathing in hot air, hot air, you're just...
Sweaty and sticky all the time when it's humid, so it's that's that's hard to deal with for sure, but anyways...
Yeah.
Back to work.
Yeah, let me share my screen and let me share what we have prepared. The agenda stays the same, nothing there. So Marco's performance, I've been seeing like it's going good, his matrix are on track and he's grasping work well and I see him very sincere and dedicated towards work. I see him sitting.
Yeah.
Right now he's taking a call, I guess, or maybe in the meeting. I can see him like very dedicated. So it has been almost, I guess, two to three months. April he got on boarded. March he got on boarded. March end to April in May. So two months are over now. I want to know.
Yes.
Like, I would say honeymoon period is over. That was just total onboarding time that we had calculated. Now, what do you see?
Mm.
I see good things so far in terms of his CSAT score.
Is at 100% this month, and I think it was.
Last month, maybe he got one, but this month is all good, looks good. I mean, tickets that he's closing, he's at good numbers for closed tickets. In terms of collaboration with the team, he's doing really well, asking the correct questions, and I've had no complaints from my clients at all.
Yeah.
That I've been interacting with him, so...
I mean, in the first few months, he's still learning the clients. That's why it takes a little bit more time for him when he's on the phone sometimes. Some of the issues take a little bit longer because he's trying to understand the workflows and everything like that for clients. So that's not a big problem for me. Eventually, that time on the phones will
get less and less because he understands the workflows and knows the individuals he's dealing with. So I can I cannot point to anything that I'm unhappy about.
Oh, that's really great to see that you are happy with this performance and everything. So that's really a good sign. Moving on next, like performance analysis, utilization is always up mark. So we know that's going good. If I see his ticket closures, they are less because.
Yeah.
He had leaves and there was one holiday as well. Average ticket closures per day is Accounting to 7.7. What a good number looks for you for general in the team.
Amit.
Yes.
Generally in the team, I always say we're aiming for that 10. So anything 10 is good for everybody on the team. And that's not just for him. It's for everybody on the team. Essentially, I always encourage and say, hey, if you can get to 10 closes a day, that's great.
Okay.
Correct.
But I also understand that there are days when our volume of tickets is lower, or weeks when volume of ticket is lower, so not everybody is able to achieve that 10 close. And that will ebb and flow as weeks interchange. And I think that's not a big problem.
problem, but it's just a matter of when we do have a lot of volume, then most of the technicians on the team will call us more than 10 tickets. So I get the fluctuation there, but ideally the goal is towards aim for that 10.
Oh, great.
Yeah, so I guess May and June where we would see low volume and then from July the action would start building up again.
The volume picks up. It depends on which clients are busier when. So it's not everybody gets busy around this time. It's a few clients that get busy at different seasons of their business operations. That's when we get to see a few more tickets. But things do slow down from time to time, even.
Okay.
in busy seasons.
We don't always see an uptick completely upward trajectory. It's some weeks are high, others are low, others are high. Mostly when we see a lot of the highs is around September and January when schools are starting out, people are coming back from holidays.
Okay.
that sort of thing. So now we are going into the summer, people are taking holidays, kind of it slows down a little bit as people are taking time off and going out on holidays.
But on the back end of the summer, when people are coming back, then it picks up again.
Okay.
That's kind of what you can expect in terms of that.
But I'm pretty happy with his average at the minute because he's still only three months in.
Okay, and coming on to holidays, are you going on a or planning on a holiday?
So.
I am planning to be on holidays. First 2 weeks of August, I'll be away.
Okay, yeah. That's great. Great to hear that. And any specific place you are going to?
Yeah.
Usually I go to BC, British Columbia, the other province. We are currently in Alberta here, so I usually go to BC with my family, so that's where we'll be going again.
Okay, a fixed destination then.
Yeah, it's a fixed, usually it's a fixed destination. It makes it easy for the kids routine-wise. We've been going there for the past few years, so we have a spot we go to and we make that our...
Yeah.
Lab.
boarding space and then we kind of go from different places within that.
Okay, Gary.
Within the BC area, yeah.
Great to hear that.
How about you? Are you going on vacation anytime?
Not anytime soon, but maybe I'll plan something in December.
Right, right, yeah, December, Christmas comes in. Most people take time off around December too.
Yeah, and that's where we have...
I might have a day or two here and there as well, but we'll see.
Yeah.
Moving on to CSAT, his CSATs are really good. 30 surveys, all 100%. With low volume of tickets that he handled, 30 surveys and 116 tickets, that's really good numbers. So that's really going good. I see higher numbers going forward because he would be handling more tickets.
Moving on to leaves, so no one planned leaves or planned leaves. Everything going good. He did not mention any upcoming leaves as of now, but if there would be, we'll let you know.
Okay.
Yeah, he didn't. It's just next week he's writing exams and whatnot. So I did give authorization for him to work from home where possible, if he can. If he's got the setup for that, then that way he's not having to drive just long distance to get to the office after the exam.
Yeah.
To come and work, so I said he's fine to work from home.
Yeah, person, but our setup with the F12 is that we need to work from office only. So that's one thing that he would have to travel along. I said, like he said, like he already spoke with you and he might be an hour or so late. I said, that's okay. You take time. Do not rush to come to office. I'll.
Right.
Okay.
I know present and I will understand on this situation because you have papers coming in and we cannot give you leads. So that is okay.
Mhm.
Okay, no, that's fine. I did ask him to talk to you guys because I thought there was restrictions from accessing our environment from outside your office. So if that's the case, I'm fine with him if he is running late. If he's 30 minutes, an hour late, that's fine too.
Yep.
important that he gets through his exams. So whatever you can accommodate there, whatever you've given him as a directive, I'm fine with that.
No worries.
Thank you, Prasan, for your help and support here. Moving on next way forward, like we'll continue with Marcos on ensuring that he is improving on his metrics and being more consistent. So that is one goal that we want to achieve. Like he takes, he reduces on his time.
on ticket handling, specifically on calls, that would be a goal forward. But yes, overall his performance is good and we are really happy with it.
Mhm.
Yes, yes. So I'm happy with the performances. And like any other, I mean, it's not a big issue right now that he's taking as much time on the phone sometimes. And it's not all the calls. It's some calls where he maybe sometimes he's on the phone for 45 minutes, maybe an hour and that sort of thing. But again,
Yep.
Different clients, we have so many other different clients that he's...
and interacting with so many individuals within those organizations that he's dealing with at separate time. Some of them, it's the first time he's interacting with them and that sort of thing. So understanding their workflows can take time and asking the right questions. He is asking the right questions. I've typed, I've worked and reviewed some of the calls and listened in on the calls to see what's going on. And so far, I'm happy with what I'm hearing and what I'm seeing. So I do.
Okay.
It'll come with time. And I think he only get better in terms of managing his court time with different individuals as he gets familiar with them. So it's not a big deal for now.
Yeah, that's.
Yeah, so I know this will take time and every tech takes their own time in settling in and so, but I can see him settling in very fast. So I think like that change would not take much time. So apart from this, anything else, Vishal, you want to share with us?
Yeah.
No, I don't have anything else. It was a good conversation, good chat. Thanks for sharing the metrics and how it's going on. I have my own here that I watched too, but I think it's looking good on both ends, which is what we're going for anyways.
Oh, great. Great to hear. Thank you so much, Persian, for your time. Have a great day.
Alright, thanks. Yeah, thanks for your time, Shashank.
Thanks, bye.